[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté
enfin et oui enfin nous nous sommes
quittés le 15 mars au soir du premier
tour et nous voilà enfin pour la suite
de ces élections municipales le second
tour qui aura lieu le dimanche 28 juin
france 3 franche comté consacre 9
soirées à partir d'aujourd'hui chaque
soir à 18 heures à des débat d'entre
deux tours avec les villes est donc avec
les candidats des neuf villes les plus
importantes de franche-comté toujours à
pourvoir à savoir lons le saunier
saint-claude et salins les bains
héricourt belfort bavilliers et donc
besançon valentigney et mandeure
besançon ouvrait fermera sets serrés
besançon au programme de ce soir est un
nouveau débat très différent vous sera
proposé jeudi prochain le 25 juin alors
trois invités sur ce plateau
les trois qualifiés ils ont dépassé la
barre des 10%
synonyme de qualification pour le second
tour à besançon arrivé en tête des
suffrages avec 31% des voix
anne vignot d'europe écologie les verts
elle conduit une liste de gauche avec
aussi le ps le pcf et génération ludovic
fagots des républicains il a pris la
deuxième place avec 24% des voix il est
également élu conseiller départemental
vice président en charge de la culture
et puis eric alauzet de la république en
marche est arrivé troisième avec 19 %
des voix
il est député lrm de la deuxième
circonscription du doubs alors je vous
propose de revoir les résultats du
premier tour donc comme je vous le
disais en tête à une vigneault en de
ludovic fagots eric alauzet en troisième
position aurait pu fusionner avec ses
listes qualifiées du trio tête car ils
ont réalisé plus de 5% des voix de liste
la quatrième celle de claire arnoux de
la france a soumise avec plus de 10% des
voix et celle du candidat du
rassemblement national jacques richard
des ti 7%
mais ces fusions n'ont pas eu lieu je
vous laisse lire les résultats des
autres listes nous allons voir comment
ces trois candidats qualifiés espère
s'ils sont élus maire de besançon rendre
la ville plus dynamique plus attractive
plus écolo est aussi plus sûres
mais on est bien évidemment obligé de
parler de ce qui nous a marqué tous au
cours des derniers mois à savoir
l'épidémie de kovy 19
on va commencer par un tour de table
avec vous d'abord anne vignot qu'est ce
que ça a changé cette épidémie dans
votre vie et aussi dans votre programme
s'il y a eu des changements je pense que
ça a changé beaucoup de choses dans la
vie de tout le monde et la première
chose c'est que ça nous a ramenés sur la
question de l'essentiel l'essentiel la
solidarité qui s'est beaucoup montré
comme étant un élément fort et qui a
tenu la société et bien sûr la question
de la santé et la question de l'écologie
puisque on a vu que cette relation santé
écologie était très importante
donc ça nous a plongés dans l'essentiel
et notre programme était très axé sur
finalement ces grands enjeux là et donc
du coup on n'a pas changé radicalement
le programme
on a peut-être prioriser un certain
nombre de choses et des actions beaucoup
plus forte sur des politiques qui va
falloir mettre très vite en action
ludovic fagots pour vous mes côtés je
pense que cette épidémie nous a montré
cette ville d'art et vulnérabilités
qu'on pouvait avoir en matière sanitaire
notamment et en matière aussi de
logistique
ça a été clairement identifiés et puis
cette fracture aussi désormais qu'elles
soient sociales ou économiques on le
voit de ce que nous avance donc les
statistiques de la de la cci nous disons
qu'aujourd'hui la chambre d'industrie
nous disons aujourd'hui que un quart de
nos entreprises sont en péril donc nous
avons continué à travailler pendant
cette période d'épidémie avec l'ensemble
des colistiers notre programme avait
vraiment du sens qui était celui de
remettre de la vie dans la ville
on a écrit un plan de relance un plan de
relance économique très fort parce
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises ont
besoin de développer et donc on l'a
vraiment réécrit avec un projet de
relance immédiat qu'il faudra développer
aujourd'hui eric alauzet quels
changements pour vous on a vu à la fois
les fragilités la société et de belle
solidarité
et finalement ce que j'ai fait moi
pendant ces trois mois dans ma vie
personnelle et parallèlement pour mon
programme municipal ces trois sujets
l'économie la santé et les solidarités
l'économie parce que j'étais en relation
quotidiennement avec les chefs
d'entreprises y siègent au gouvernement
pour construire le plan de relance et
confirme le plan ici de 120 millions
d'euros sur la santé pour aller
fois reprendre mon rôle de médecin et
faire en sorte que l'hôpital ne soit pas
trop surcharger à ma place mais aussi
mettre en exergue nos propositions pour
la santé qui existait déjà mais qu'on a
mis beaucoup plus fort et puis enfin les
solidarités ça a été l'occasion pour
nous de mettre en oeuvre une proposition
la campagne et la banque du bénévolat
qui a permis d'assister des enfants pour
avoir des ordinateurs de fabriquer des
masques de venir se livrer des repas aux
personnes âgées et finalement de de
préparer ce qui va se passer
malheureusement que le chômage qui
s'annonce
ah oui disent y ait des points qui ont
été renforcées dans votre programme et
ce qui est des choses que vous avez
abandonné en vous disant on n'aura pas
le temps n'aura pas l'argent non on n'a
rien abandonné on a juste repris au rize
est par exemple dans le programme il y
avait une question très forte sur la
question de la fonte et et que vous
voulez un sans pareil parce qu'on
considérait que c'était vraiment un
manque
et finalement on va le mettre très
fortement mais pourtant la santé c'est
pas forcément une priorité mais une
compétence municipale à écouter il ya un
moment donné ce qui nous importe c'est
aussi les là où on voit qu'il ya des
difficultés dans la ville
donc c'est pour ça que c'était pas
marqué comme étant une grande des
priorités mais c'est elle est devenu lé
de voile elle a pris là est la deuxième
à me replacer la deuxième qui a pris une
place encore plus importante qu'elle
n'était avant c'est bien sûr la
fragilité dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui en niveau écologique et au
niveau économique que je veux dire et au
niveau social parce qu'elle n'a pas su
sur quel lapsus oui parce que l'écologie
c'est sans doute c'est le moyen de
sortir l'économie de la houle elle peut
se trouver
ludovic fagots vous vous parlez
télécabine pour la citadelle des
circuits en ville toute grosse pas
réservé au tourisme tout ça vous l'avez
mis de côté ou pas alors on l'a pas mis
de côté c'est à dire que ça va être
décalés dans le temps parce que je pense
que cette période amène de la
responsabilité
donc le projet fort projet pour
citadelle bien sûr bien sûr est toujours
d'actualité mais il sera un petit peu
décalé dans le temps on a surtout et
travailler sur le volet économique volet
économique avec un plan de relance à
hauteur de 32 millions d'euros
immédiatement parce qu'aujourd'hui les
entreprises ont besoin de ce qu'on
appelle le cash-flow ses dires du flux
de trésorerie pour pouvoir abondé
vraiment leurs fonds disponibles ce qui
est compliqué aujourd'hui et on le voit
qu'on a un certain nombre aujourd'hui de
deux personnes qui sont en doute de
savoir c'est mon pouvoir maintenir ou
pas leur emploi et donc il faut réagir
dans l'immédiat et donc le plan de
relance que l'on
à travailler qu on a à construire avec
332 millions eric alauzet disais tout à
l'heure 120 écoutez je pense qu'il faut
pas être sûr de la surenchère 120
millions quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
que le grand paris avec 7,7 millions
d'habitants fait un plan de relance à
110 millions d'euros -nous 190 mille
habitants sur le grand besançon un plan
de 120 millions d'euros je crois qu'il
faut avoir un petit peu de sérieux par
rapport à cela en tout cas c'est pas
forcément l'objet ne sait pas forcément
l'objet du débat mais on s'en va militer
sur un plan immédiat 120 millions pour
quoi faire vous les trouvez vous voulez
pas vous parler de la santé
c'était de notre programme simplement
elle a mis en exergue
il ya beaucoup de choses il ya la santé
sur les compétences municipales bien
manger bien respirer se déplacer d'une
certaine façon mais aussi toutes nos
startups sur le pôle tes me sentais
qu'ils sont avec l'établissement
français du sang sur des médicaments
innovants pour l'avenir mais aussi
beaucoup de choses sur la santé et mon
emblème pour la vie de me lancer mon
ambition c'était de faire de besançon la
ville delà de la pleine santé
les habitants de la plaine santé donc on
a mis tout ça en exergue mais aussi bien
sur la vie quotidienne que sur le
développement et économique toile et
maintenant la question économique et les
massives
il va falloir faire vite et fort
l'agglomération c'est une compétence
majeure l'économie il va falloir pas
faire de la dépense pour la dépense
comme le faisait parce que c'est fait
monsieur fagots de 32 millions à fonds
perdus c'est de l'investissement que
nous allons faire y compris des prises
de participations dans les entreprises
pour faire justement que ces entreprises
qui sont à la pointe comme une start up
dans le médical il faut 7 8 ans pour
développer un produit et c'est voir s'il
en trouvait à son soit rachetée elle
partait s'externalise et nous on veut
développer ici ces entreprises les
transmet les industrialiser ici et pour
ça la collectivité et pas seulement avec
l'europe avec la frange alors qu'ils se
préparent au niveau repas et français on
va lui donner la parole à mme vignaud un
mot oui parce que juste moins vis
quelque chose qui m'interrogent parce
que le au premier tour nous avions dit
que nous voulions être ambitieux en
matière d'investissement et quand nous
annoncions à l'époque 10 millions
d'euros par exemple sur la rénovation
des écoles plus 9 millions sur l'énergie
renouvelable sur un certain nombre de
deux d'orientation pour que justement ça
soutiennent l'économie mais ce que ça
aille aussi dans le sens de la
transition écologique c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
et bien mes deux adversaires
les deux candidats qui sont là me disais
que c'était irresponsable
aujourd'hui j'entends des chiffres dont
je ne connais pas exactement la nature
ça m'intéresse justement d'explorer d'où
viennent tous ces millions parce que moi
j'étais en train d'aller sur de
l'emprunt et donc parce que nous avions
la chance d'avoir une ville qui n'était
pas endettée qui avait une capacité d
endettement important
on m'a qu'on m'accusait
d'irresponsabilité donc je renvoie la
balle aujourd'hui sans moi je vois bien
les millions que vous pouvez mettre en
oeuvre mais je suis très intéressé de
voir que vous avez suivi
l'ambition que nous avons tracée dès le
premier tour il de vic fagots
écoutez je pense que le débat ce soir il
est surtout un débat de fond on n'est
pas sur la surenchère
aujourd'hui comme en matière financière
monsieur la lozère par 220 millions
parle de 32 millions alors on est tous
sur des projets un petit peu différent
certainement mais on n'appelle pas là à
la surenchère des chiffres je crois que
l'époque ne se prête pas au brassage
d'utopie je pense ni ni à fantaisie
dogmatique en tout cas comme vous voulez
avancer
je vous aime parce que je ne faisais pas
forcément mais il est juste que je suis
une femme et il est vrai que vous
arrêtiez de m'attaquer sur des motels
muller qui sont propres à donner une âme
madame ici vous le dis si vous pensez
vraiment que j'étais vraiment très
attentif à ce que vous à ces quelques
mots qu'il a employés mais moi je vous
savez depuis qu' on est honda mais paris
est le mot qui l'appliquent on est en
campagne on est sûr angélisme chasse aux
papillons etc
ce monsieur ne voit même pas que les
femmes qui font de l'angélisme la chasse
aux papillons made
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas au courant
qu'il ya du vocabulaire qui est utilisé
dans le monde politique qui a tendance à
discréditer en une parole en voulant
abaisser en permanence avec eux la laque
ses vols sur ce plateau
certains plateaux moi je n'ai pas de
sexe je suis journaliste l'asvel famille
que symbole phallique
oui je sais pas c'est que si je sais que
je vais juste expliquer l'histoire
muscles et symboles phalliques oui c'est
un propos de la police municipale et son
âme et mon potentiel
on en parlera bien leur fasse une sfl
gautrain finissez votre moi j'ai été
très attentif à ce que vous avez voté je
vous ai pas couper parce que je suis
très respectueux en tout cas de
l'engagement qui est le vôtre
donc voilà respecter un petit peu mon
ma prise de parole donc voilà je ne suis
pas là dessus et puis quand vous parlez
de certains éléments
voyez on m'a parlé des bêtes je crois
tout à l'heure vous voulez du béton avec
moi je veux des fleurs dont vous voyez
je pense qu'il ya pas forcément elle est
autant les pcistes ça on va rentrer au
parc aux éléments économiques
je compte sur vous allez voir comment
vous allez en parler là tout de suite
nous en avons vous allez en avoir
l'occasion puisque donc on va parler
d'économie puisque très touché par le
confinement et le manque d'activité
économique les commerçants ceux qui font
vivre la ville qui apporte de la vida
unités du dynamisme en son centre
alors on va écouter maintenant la
question que pose que vous pose thierry
bisch qui est président de l'association
des commerçants de besançon on les
écoute
mesdames messieurs bonjour messieurs
dames les candidats j'ai bien sûr une
question pour vous qui concerne le
centre ville
alors on est tous fort de constater que
le centre-ville est moribond on a perdu
notre capitale régionale on perd des
habitants on perd de l'attractivité
alors aujourd'hui concrètement qu'allez
vous nous proposez je voudrais une
action une action précise à mettre en
oeuvre rapidement pour redonner au
centre ville la notoriété qu'elle a
perdu alors par galanterie ludovic fargo
je vais vous donner la parole vous
parler d'économie là monsieur dit je
vous pose une question quelles actions
concrètes pour le centre-ville alors
c'est multifactoriel dans les actions
qu'ils aient besoin des pina alors il y
en a certainement plusieurs à développer
mais l'animation du centre-ville
aujourd'hui est un élément
incontournable à porter encore
construisant vraiment avec avec les
commerçants aujourd'hui pour faire vivre
vraiment notre docteur d'activité mais
c'est aussi le stationnement
c'est d'abord une politique de
stationnement tarifaire incitative ce
qu'on a toujours porté durant ce mandat
avec sur la période 2010 deux banques la
gratuité est là dans le cadre du plan de
relance de porter donc la gratuité donc
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 sur les
samedis sur les parkings en surface
donc si je comprends bien gratuité entre
midi et deux c'est pour donner un coup
de pouce aux restaurateurs aux
commerçants d'une façon générale mais
vous avez aussi bien sur cette animation
du coeur de ville regarder le marché de
noël
il va falloir donner les moyens vraiment
aujourd'hui un anneau acteurs
associatifs de pouvoir porter des
éléments d'envergure sur le territoire
mais je voudrais aussi aborder cette
politique aussi affirmé en matière donc
de tranquillité publique ne lutte contre
les incivilités depuis
la sortie du confinement notre ville est
sale et pas du fait des agents qui font
bien leur travail mais du fait aussi des
incivilités aujourd'hui au club de
sécurité à eric alauzet eric alauzet une
action pour redynamiser le centre ville
vous demande le président embellir
embellir et faciliter les déambulations
dans dans le centre-ville fournée
plaisir de voir de regarder de se
rencontrer en mairie
ça veut dire qu à metz défense les arcs
place voyez quand l'état de la place
jean corne est l'état de la place victor
hugo
l'état de ce qui a été fait sur la place
du 8 septembre la minéralisation de la
place voilà tout ça ce n'est pas de
nature à se rencontrer la minéralisation
c'est le contraire de la végétalisation
la minéralisation c'est justement cette
les deux on est en ville quand même un
papa faire que que du végétal mais il
faut combiner ça et puis l'accessibilité
qui se fait non seulement en voiture par
une gratuité deux heures tous les jours
pas seulement entre midi et deux heures
tous les jours en voiture mais aussi un
tarif pour l'accès en bus le samedi et
dimanche samedi c'est laquelle plus de
monde
un euro le ticket de bus aller et retour
pour une famille avec trois enfants de
moins de 12 ans aujourd'hui l'aller
retour
ça fait 14 euros si on fait gratuit pour
les enfants de moins de 12 ans et notre
proposition est un euro aller-retour
pour les parents savaient 2 euros pour
la famille pour descendre en ville le
samedi pour les courses le dimanche par
la culture mais le dimanche soir il peut
y avoir aussi de l'animation commerciale
anne vignot une action symbolique le
centre ville eh bien nous on l'a reçue
on part sur le court terme c'est à
dépend de quel type de projet on veut
l'idée c'est de d'envisager ce qu'on
appelle une carte avantages estivale
c'est à dire proposer que y ait un
ensemble d'accords entre les commerçants
et les artisans etc pour proposer un
ensemble de deux services mais aussi de
loisirs sur l'ensemble du centre ville
il ya des choses qui ont déjà été fait
ailleurs monsieur fagots parle par
exemple du prix d'entrée 12h02 mais
c'est déjà en train d'être mis en place
et donc le lit des rivières king entre
me dit voilà c'est ce nom du prix du
parking entre midi et deux et donc
monsieur à leuze et parle de aussi la
gratuité mais ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faudra discuter avec
l'agglomération de pas la gratuité de 1
euro le samedi nous allons nous sur la
gratuité le samedi pour qu'effectivement
les familles puissent descendre
massivement au centre ville
et bien sûr la fin de l'extension est là
c'est sur du plus long terme l'extension
des grandes zones artisanales et
commerciales qui sont en concurrence
permanence avec notre centre ville
donc de toutes façons c'est une approche
globale avec des actions qui ont des
temps différents des temps immédiat et
des temps plus long qu'il faudra
travailler
vous proposez également vous que les
loyers pour les terras soit annulée qui
est une exonération de charges etc vous
proposer tout ça c'est parti un point
commun on la trouve un point commun donc
le proposait sa part que la bataille
mais en fait on est dans la même
municipalité là et donc on a tous décidé
d'aller vers ce genre de propositions
dont on est tous d'accord sur cet
accompagnement là parce que vous êtes
quand même économiquement vous pensez
que c'est nécessaire que la ville aide
les gens à vos centres villes
les commerçants notamment vous pensez
qu'il faut leur apporter un petit coup
de pouce tard en ces périodes difficiles
bien sûr on a besoin de nos commerces on
a besoin d'une vie à économique forte
importante
ça fait partie aussi bien sûr de l'enjeu
de l'attractivité mais aussi de bien
vivre
on a besoin de deux commerces qui soit
aussi en capacité d'apporter des
réponses rapides on a vu que pendant le
coc vide heureusement que nous avions
des personnes qui avaient l'alimentaire
par exemple qui était très présent donc
on a besoin d'une ville il est si fier
dans son ludovic wagons plus
généralement l'économie vous voyez ça
comment vous parce que vous nous parler
de relations privilégiées avec la suisse
du savoir faire horloger et c'était au
premier tour on voit que l'horlogerie en
suisse ne va pas très bien là non mais
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'horlogerie en
suisse se tournait aussi bien les pays
asiatiques tout naturellement et on a pu
le voir dernièrement dans un magazine
donc sur les échos par exemple où il
disait que l'horlogerie suisse allait
certainement se retourner vers l'arc
jurassien dans lequel se trouve le
département du doubs mais se trouve
aussi le secteur bisontin donc nous
avons vraiment une carte à jouer dans
cette relation au franco suisse sur le
savoir-faire horloger
surtout que on va avoir le label le
label unesco du savoir faire horloger
qui va arriver très prochainement
donc nous avons vraiment une carte à
jouer dans cette relation transfo trader
mais plus largement l'attractivité elle
et touristique
elle est bien sûr aussi d'événementiel
pour relancer vraiment l'activité
mystique là on vous espérez que les
français peut-être du grand test pour du
sud pourquoi pas pourrait venir chez
nous cet été mais de l'ensemble de
l'hexagone de l'ensemble de l'hexagone
voilà je parle des plus proches soi même
les langues puisque voyez bien que les
frontières aujourd'hui européennes sont
à nouveau ouvertes
donc il va falloir aussi communiquer sur
notre savoir faire sur nos atouts
touristiques patrimoniaux aussi ici sur
le territoire donc moi je serai le maire
vrp de mon territoire de pouvoir aller
vraiment porter ce qu'il a de beaux ici
a besoin de sous mais il ya aussi des
erreurs à ne pas commettre
allez planter une base de téléphérique
télécabine auprès de vos c'est une
erreur magistrale
ça c'est ça qui les emmène sans même si
jeune et si les commerçants la cellule
de ses soeurs le craignent aussi parce
que ça emmène les touristes
de l'autre côté des prés de vaux il
monte à la citadelle il y aura des
cendres ils partent la citadelle elle se
conquiert au sens figuré du terme par le
centre ville par la place victor hugo
spriet montée en l1 c'est une montée on
agrémente 90% des gens peu la montée
tranquillement du manque elle est
agrémentée qu'elle est agréable que les
facilités et mon projet des plus tôt
dynamiser l'intérieur la citadelle offre
l'essai est de faire de la boot du
centre ville la boutique il ya une
petite boutique là où elle est utile
mais la vraie boutique de la citadelle
c'est centre ville donc donc le lien
entre la citadelle et la boucle ses
parts en montant comme on l'a fait
historiquement il faut aussi éviter de
faire deux on va y revenir sur les bêtes
il faut construire howett et on peut pas
dire qu'on veut assurer l'attractivité
de la ville et dont je vous avais tu
connais pas surtout de supprimer des
mots doux samedi
heureusement que la caméra un délai de
réponse mais il assume et là il faut
juste que j'apporte à tout petit et
éclairage ludovic fagots vice-président
de la culture aux causes au conseil
départemental du doubs l'une des
premières décisions qui a été prise par
cette nouvelle majorité
ça a été de supprimer les mots doux qui
était une manifestation du terrain qui
marchait j'allais dire du feu de dieu
enfin voilà qui marchait très bien alors
deux éléments parce que je pense que
faire de la politique ça amène à voir un
peu d'honnêteté intellectuelle dans les
éléments quand vous parlez de bus
télécabine de la télécabine
il faut pas il faut penser que c'est un
continuum centre-ville près de vous
citer quand on le voit et qu'on échange
qu'on le veuille laisser parler ici et
quand on le voit vos choix je me doutais
un petit peu de comment allait se
dérouler ce débat aujourd'hui ça va
faire la politique ça demande aussi
d'avoir du sang froid et je vois
aujourd'hui que depuis dix ans qu'on est
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
vous qui êtes dans cette majorité
sortante combien de touristes nouveaux
sont arrivés de prix que nous sommes
inscrits au patrimoine mondial unique
pas la deuxième chose
la deuxième chose sur les mots doux
enfin j'ai voulu rappeler quand même
monsieur halouze et un transfert à un
certain moment que vous étiez sous le
gouvernement de françois hollande
donc vous avez quand même aussi serré
les départements notamment donc ça il
faut quand même le ramener on intervient
qu on a perdu du mais bon j'ai perdu un
certain nombre aussi c'est de mag ont lé
nancière et juste pour terminer le sang
froid cela est bien le ballon aussi en
une phrase il va falloir rappeler aussi
qu'il est dommage que quand la
présidente du département à cette
adresse et un bon président de
l'agglomération pour pouvoir porter
collectivement et conjointement cette
manifestation et les prennent sur eux se
bat ce qui est dommage monsieur favorise
avait explosé votre temps de parole déjà
allez on va passer au deuxième thème de
ce débat à savoir donc le cadre de vie
l'écologie les transports etc
alors là des dossiers qui a été très
présente dans cette cape de cette
campagne c'est l'fun jardins ont des
voeux est donc le projet mené par
l'actuelle majorité dont vous faites
partie
eric alauzet et anne vignot voulait en
construire 1100 50 logements sur un
cadre de 23 hectares donc on va écouter
maintenant la coprésidente de
l'association du jardin des bêtes qui
vous pose une question qui s'adresse à
vous trois on écoute
bonjour marie hélène parrot de
l'association des jardins d'éveil tu
considérez-vous alors que nous sommes
avons une période de réchauffement
climatique et de
fragilisation de la biodiversité et du
vivant qu'il soit urgent d'urbaniser 23
hectares de jardins populaires de zones
humides howett
ne serait-il pas plus intelligents a
besoin sont de protéger la nature à cet
endroit de protéger les jardins d'en
construire d'autres et éventuellement
d'installer des nouveaux maraîchers en
bio howett
anne vignot le numéro 2 de votre lit
s'appelle nicolas baudin et les
socialistes c'est lui qui en tant qu
adjoint à l'urbanisme mener ce projet
dévêtent vous aujourd'hui vous en dites
quoi de ce projet vous arrêtez tout vous
construisez autrement vous continuez oui
ce projet il a été pensé il ya plus
qu'un de plus de 15 ans et donc il avait
à l'époque vraiment des objectifs
extrêmement écologistes et pour pour
autant il ya des choses qui se sont sur
imposé c'est à dire la question de la
biodiversité des zones humides etc
donc puisque le débat est posé et qu'il
est important nous avons décidé que des
si nous avons la ville le 28 juin
eh bien nous convoquerons un groupe
d'experts scientifiques ce qu'on appelle
le giec locales pour analyser justement
l'impact de du projet tel qu'il avait
été pensé et pourvoir dans la mesure où
oui là vous faites en quelque sorte
plaisir à la france info me gérard nous
a rien du tout qui est donc aussi une
membre de cette association willy a
réalisé lui pour cent lors du premier
tour c'était pas possible de maintenant
tendre avec elle entre les deux tout la
jugerait sur ce banc des sources qui a
été dit oui il est strictement pas
possible qu'on puisse envisager la
question de la biodiversité
l'aménagement du territoire de
l'ensemble du grand besançon qu'à
travers le prisme des bêtes
il est très symbolique il est
intéressant et y pose un certain nombre
de questions c'est pour ça que le groupe
d'experts travaillera à partir de ce
dossier là mais pas uniquement sur ce
dossier là quant à l'avenir nos meubles
écologiques sur la question de la france
insoumise juste les questions que vous
posez
saïd et son cheval de bataille pendant
bien sûr c'était une valeur symbolique
sur laquelle ils se sont construits
d'accord donc évidemment il pose des
questions qui sont très proches des
nôtres
je pense que la plupart des militants de
france info me sont très proches du
programme que nous avons construit pour
autant dans l'expression politique telle
qu'elle a été posée à la au soir des
élections
la france est soumise nous a donné des
conditions qui nous ont pas permis de
nous unir
mais je sais combien les militants sont
attachées au travail de l'écologie et
dont contrat ira tous ensemble parce que
de toute façon si on veut transformer la
ville de besançon
il faut qu'on amène un maximum de
personnes qui sont engagées dans cette
question d'écologie qu'il soit sur une
échelle de 10 à 2 ou à 8
elle en entraînera tout le monde eric
alauzet vous les faites vous en pensez
quoi vous fait quoi si vous êtes maire
le 28 juin faut prendre un peu de
hauteur
l'enjeu du développement d'une ville ses
habitants et ses dernières années ce
qu'on observe c'est que toutes les
nouvelles habitations les nouveaux
habitants surtout à l'extérieur de
besançon stagnation sur besançon
développement en périphérie voyez ce que
ça génère comme transport comme
pollution et ses adjoints s'est
équilibré moitié en ville moitié à la
périphérie
donc on a un gros déficit pourquoi parce
qu'on n'a pas de logement qualitatif
offrira aux bisontins et à prix
abordable
c'est à dire des logements avec des
espaces privatifs extérieur qui ouvre
sur la nature et c'est pour cela qu'il
faut construire je vais je vais revoir
le projet des dettes aussi mais qu'il
faut construire au cdc des logements
sociaux privés de tous et la mixité
c'est damistes et il faut absolument
construire
howett sinon on renvoie les habitants à
la périphérie
c'est complètement anti écologique
simplement il faut faire un quartier où
la biodiversité ou les jardins sont
présents mais n'a pas mis c'est la
partie de tram sur cette partie là ça
fait 16 millions d'euros
il ya une école qui est prévu à 12
millions d'euros si on fait pas ces
projets là il faut faire un bassin
d'orage pour retenir l'eau sinon ça sert
naturellement avec le projet des bêtes
s'est à nouveau 12 millions d'euros
c'est un gâchis monumental
ouais c'est une aberration écologique de
transformer ces bêtes de ne pas le faire
vivre
c'est une aberration écologique c'est
une aberration économique pour le centre
ville c'est une population qui a acquis
nommé tweet du centre-ville qui vient à
pied en vélo qui consomme au
centre-ville pour l'attractivité de la
vie du centre ville c'est
hyper-important moi je vais le revoir
mais pas avec des experts ça n'apportera
aucun crédit que ni le jugement le
jugement qui sera favorable à la ville
probablement du salon vous faites
référence dans cette moyenne tension
c'est la convention climat qui se passe
au niveau national sous scellés swing
les citoyens qui construisent le projet
pas des experts n'y aura pas de crédit
bic manoel va donner la mort franchement
20 secondes pas plus que vous avez visé
très très en avance les bêtes vous
voulez en faire une thérapie et sociaux
une ferme urbaine exactement moi je
refuse en fait si vous voulez que
besançon soit ce laboratoire de
l'écologie communiste poussant vraiment
à l'extrême gauche comme nous ça nous
est proposée par par madame vidéo
culpabilisant idéologique et c'est un
sujet moi qui me passionne les bêtes
parce que si vous voulez je me suis
toujours opposée vraiment à cette
bétonisation que vous avez porté
conjointement pendant ce mandat et nous
avons un projet vraiment absolument
essentiel sur le cet espace des bêtes
avec cette grande ferme urbaine que nous
allons développer avec des parcours
ludique dédié 30 secondes et bientôt on
va dire venez sur sûr cela vraiment le
legault jamais anciaux c'est vraiment un
poumon vert je ne sais pas
est ce que je peux apporter un éclairage
la ferme urbaine elle a été installée
nous avons installé dans les serres qui
existe est là et ça j'en suis madame
madame madame vous allez me laisser
terminer sur la baisse d'une arme et on
va voir vous c'est du béton il avait
porté pendant 7 vous avez un il faut
laver l'eau de l'engagement qui est
juste très préconçues très pas du tout
juste moi ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'au concrètement nous avons installé
une micro ferme à cet endroit là nous
avons nous devons réinstaller un certain
nombre de jardins une légumerie c'est
nous qui l'avons mis en oeuvre dans leur
conception d'options de france 2 on va
arrêter sur les cdo des noms mais je
suis désolé on va dire qu'on va pas
parler que des wetz parce qu'il reste de
12 minutes et je voudrais qu'on aborde
un thème qui a été très présent dans
dans la première partie de cette
campagne à savoir la sécurité
on va écouter vous savez que ce matin
une très grosse opération de police a
été menée 1 planoise il ya eu quinze
interpellations
des policiers sont venus de dijon de
nancy et d'ailleurs pour arrêter donc
des gens à planoise
on va écouter tout de suite le
l'un des syndicalistes de la police
municipale de besançon il s'appelle ivan
d'écrouer on écoute il a une question à
vous poser
bonjour madame bonjour messieurs j'aime
présent qui vont de couy délégué
syndical force ouvrière à la pm de
besançon et j'aurai une question à vous
poser dans le climat d'angélisme actuel
et au vu des faits réels qui se passe
sur le terrain dans la ville de besançon
des morts des trafics diverses et des
incivilités qui gêne considérablement la
vie des bisontins et byzantine
j'aimerais savoir quels seront vos
orientations pour la sécurité et la
tranquillité plus vite qui sont du
ressort du maire de besançon et quels
moyens humains et matériels vous mettrez
à disposition donc en parlant de
sécurité donc ce syndicaliste parle de
climat d'angélisme
vous en avez parlé vous même de
l'angélisme tout à l'heure est ce que
vous vous sentez visé
et qu'est ce que vous mettez qu'aux
moyens humains et matériels à la police
nationale à la police municipale pardon
alors du coup on a fait une introduction
avec la police nationale
oui donc j'aimerais revenir quand même
sur cet épisode qui n'est pas rien
d'être anodin parce que vous savez très
bien que j'avais pris une position très
très forte qui consistait à dire l'état
doit être présent doit nous apporter
cette protection
je les salue et je salue le travail qui
fait pas recette police nationale c'est
fondamental ce sont des vrais
professionnels de la criminalité on est
d'accord
ensuite pour la question de l'incivilité
là on est sur d'autres critères
et moi j'ai travaillé très fortement
avec l'ensemble des syndicats j'ai
rencontré tous les syndicats de la
police municipale en leur promettant que
nous retravaillerons sur leur mission
parce que il est important déjà en
premier temps de savoir qui fait quoi
très bien ludovic fagots à propos de la
police nationale et municipale enfin
police nationale je suis ravi que madame
vigneault salue la police nationale d'où
votre présence certainement la
manifestation à l'encontre des policiers
nationaux de samedi donc pas j'ai pas si
vous
sur ce sujet je contextualise comme on
dit à savoir samedi y avait des
manifestations anti violence policière
madame vigneault vous y étiez alors moi
je suis arrivé au rassemblement parce
que en même temps je suis membre de la
ligue des droits de l'homme depuis très
longtemps et je défends une chose c'est
le respect je respecte et policiers je
suis très respectueuse et policiers pour
autant ça ne nous empêche pas de
rappeler qu' il y a des choses qui ne
peuvent pas arriver et c'était ce à la
demande de ce rassemblement leur et s'il
fallait que j'explique il fallait que
j'explique pourquoi ludovic faille 9
vous parlez d'une manifestation samedi
alors moi si vous voulez moi je ne
serais pas du côté de la théorie de
l'excusé si vous avez bien compris par
rapport à par rapport à cela
la situation aujourd'hui n'est plus
forcément sous contrôle à besançon le
sait on le voit les incivilités et les
insécurités gâche le quotidien des des
bisontines et des bisontins et je le
redis moi je serai le maire de la
sécurité de tous pour l'ensemble des
incivilités l'insécurité sur le
territoire bisontin donc ça passe par
différents éléments
puisqu'il faut pouvoir protéger nos
familles nos policiers municipaux qui se
retrouve face à ses 15 qui ont été
arrêtés ce matin où c'est de la grande
délinquance sont déjà lourdement armés
donc il faut recruter former et armer
nos policiers municipaux ce qu'on a
toujours défendu pendant ce mandat
mais c'est également doublé donc les
effectifs de nos policiers municipaux
s'est également déployé la visio
protection la vidéoprotection sur sur le
territoire et de redonner à nos
policiers municipaux donc des missions
de maintien de tranquillité publique
pourquoi repérer faisait police
nationale court que celui de jacques
richard d'éthique du rassemblement
national
non c'est parti la sécurité c'est comme
l'écologie ça n'appartient pas à tel ou
tel parti
on a toujours été constant par rapport à
cela contrairement à d'autres ici sur le
plateau parce qu'on a vraiment nous
cette constance par rapport à l'armement
n'a vraiment c'est justement par rapport
à l'an il y aurait 13 hectares cédés
sécuriser des trésors d'art en
protégeant les bisontines les visons
c'est vous qui est visé quand vous étiez
chez les verts vous n'étiez pas très pro
police armée la c3 le sujet privilégié
c'était pas le sujet privilégié loin de
là est là pourquoi aujourd'hui vous êtes
sur la même ligne que jacques richard
des ti dont jean mallet du rassemblement
national ou ludovic fagots du tout mais
vous voulez armée la police
nouvelle faut regarder les choses un peu
plus un peu plus au fond si vous
permettez à voir les yeux ouverts sur la
situation tient le délitement du lien
social
la perte du respect mutuel du respect
des enseignants parfois par les enfants
et même par le parent par les parents la
paire dé respect du des policiers qu'ils
soient nationaux ou municipaux qui se
font insulter provoqué craché au visage
c'est un juste intolérables et à force
de dépasser sans arrêt les limites de
soi disant la liberté y a pas de limites
il ya des limites à la liberté
et moi je veux être le maire il doit
restaurer la justice il doit restaurer
il leur resterait le respect mutuel il
doit rester restaurer le respect des
valeurs
voilà et j'y suis absolument déterminé
pour cela évidemment le rôle primordial
des parents j'aurais des contrats de
parentalité avec les parents dont les
enfants ont fait des bêtises avec les
enseignants les éducateurs en général
qu'est ce que les intérêts des bêtises
des bêtises bagdad la délinquance ond
des délits les délits oui ça c'est dit
au niveau des grosses bêtises alors des
grosses bêtises mais pas des bêtises est
quoi des groupes
mais à partir des petites bêtises on
partir des petites bêtises visiblement
buse est à peu près sur la même longueur
d'onde que monsieur phal moi je sais je
sais pas où monsieur fagots je sais ce
que je veux pour cette ville voilà et
donc je veux du respect mutuel entre les
uns et les autres mais ça passe ça passe
sur les objets qu'on jette sur la voie
publique
tiens ça voudrait dire à vos équipes qui
ramasse les affiches quand ils les
arracher tous ses succès face à 130
euros
là dessus s'est passé à 130 euros
quand on laisse les autres les affiches
et qui sont très respectueux pour
demander qui vous êtes un kiné qui qui
fait des délits paye vous serez
peut-être à monter c'est bien non le
porte bon ça on l'a quand même fait
plein à la fierté fait temps et on fait
pas elle n'arrivait pas à la télé vous
faire des ennemis des coucous fait fait
on sortait pas des manuels 2 et r je me
palmer parallèlement aux parents rôle
des parents qui est primordial des
enseignants des éducateurs des
médiateurs que la police ait déroulant
renforcée qu'elle travaille de nuit
qu'elle travaille beaucoup plus dans les
quartiers en lien avec la police
municipale et c'est tout ça je vous
préviens religieux ainsi que la police
nationale pour se protéger pour inspirer
le respect ou qui est premier notre
programme nous avons réagi de leur côté
qu'une monsieur fabre ont bombardé
bon il faut que la police ait des
missions renforcées et c'est dans ce
cadre là que il me semble impératif
indispensables comme le maire
d'audincourt d'ailleurs martial bourquin
qu'il ya des maires de gauche qui on
sait pas c'est pas la propriété de
l'extrême droite je regarde les choses
en face de façon objective je suis libre
de tout dogme qu'il soit de droite ou de
gauche et j'avance et vous pour le bien
des bisontins pour la sécurité et les
autres enjeux madame vigneault oui je
voulais juste a ajouté que nous là la
préoccupation nous avons c'est les
jeunes enfants qui se font happer par la
criminalité
doc il est certain qu'il faut mettre
tout en oeuvre pour que les familles ne
se retrouve pas seul face à l'économie
parallèle qui s'est mis en place
donc il ya la police nationale qui
s'occupe de cette économie parallèle et
nous on a l'obligation d'accompagner les
familles qui sont en difficulté quand
leurs enfants se font ap donc on a les
animateurs de rue on a bien sûr les
maisons de quartier on a évidemment tout
ce chiffre d'affaires monsieur fagots
monsieur aloses visiblement il ya quand
même des points de convergence entre
vous notamment sur la sécurité pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas à lier entre les deux
tours écoutez ça moi j'ai lancé en tout
cas des pistes 1 en tout cas sur la
prise de responsabilité des uns et des
autres donc moi j'ai pu le faire après
chacun a pris la main tendue ou pas ce
qui n'a pas aidé surtout à monsieur à
l'hôtel de s'essayer prise de
responsabilité partout en france là où
la personne est arrivée troisième
pouvait mettre un vrai risque à la ville
de besançon qu'elle soit portée par une
liste poussant à l'extrême gauche qui la
lisent le cas de la liste de madame vino
donc ça n'a pas été le cas après chacun
a pris ses responsabilités en son âme et
conscience et c'est monsieur monsieur
fagots il ya une grande partie de
l'électorat de droite qui a peur de
bananes vidéo je peux vous dire qu'à une
grande partie l'électorat de gauche l'a
énormément leur peur de choper sur les
anciennes il ya une chose qui peut
lancer une telle politique comme dans la
vie c'est le respect c'est l'ancienne
police a le respect monsieur falco et
vous je n'ai jamais vu qu'un candidat se
permettent d'intimé un autre candidat au
motif qu'il a quelques pour cent de
moins de quitter le champ politique
on va pas me montrer j'ai quand même
c'est quand même impressionnant c'est un
manque de respect élémentaire des scènes
festives landes
mais aurélie n'est que ces sacs toi et
nos programmes sont très différents il
ya des béances énorme sur l'écologie
soit les solidarités recife
si vous vous sentez touchés non c'est
pour ça vous sentez chez ineo voilà donc
l'écologie et la sincérité mais
lorsqu'on pousse à une ligne haut votre
liste elle est d'extrême gauche alors
m'écouter ça fait des années que il ya
un ensemble qui fonctionne je pense que
jamais personne n'a dit que la vie de
besançon qu'elle est un extrême gauche
que ce soit le parti commun mais le
parti communiste où ils sont
généralisation sont où les écolos vous
avez galant dans quel monde on est on
est au dix neuvième siècle quand on
enfin non mais ça ce sont des partis qui
sont en mai radicalisé par rapport à il
ya dix ans il y avait une stratégie de
langage pour et c'est essayer de faire
peur mais qui me croire alors le palais
comme basse et besançon pourrait faire
peur à qui que ce soit allez y reste ils
ont là des crédits 20 ans il reste un
peu plus de deux minutes donc le tirage
au sort pour conclure à lui avant
l'émission donc que la parole et anne
vignot vous avez 30 secondes pas plus
pour conclure on vous écoute
mais écoutez moi je suis très heureuse
de présenter aux citoyens de besançon le
programme à nouveau renouvelé
parce que je dois saluer le fait qu'on
nous a mis en premier sur la preuve le
premier tour parce que je crois qu'il y
a une culture un besançon qui est la
culture de l'écologie la culture du
social et les tout le monde y est très
attaché tout le monde donc ça c'est
fondamental et j'espère que vous voterez
tous le 28 juin une femme écologiste qui
envient l'ex transformer la ville merci
madame
ludovic fagoo 30 secondes pour vous
savez quoi donc tous les représentants
ici de la majorité sortante qui sont
autour de la table moi je fais pas
partie de leur club ils avaient le
pouvoir de changer les choses et ils ont
échoué
et en plus aujourd'hui on le voit il
essaie de se défausser de se défausser
en plus avec agressivité je crois que
besançon a rendez vous avec l'avenir moi
je ne serai pas le maire d'un clan
palmer d'un parti comme je les ai déjà
dit et avec une équipe vraiment
renouveler et dynamique nous allons
porter un nouveau projet parce que je
refuse que besançon s'illustre
aujourd'hui encore une fois dans les
faits divers mais qu'on puisse porter
vraiment nos talents et que besançon
soit la ville de tous les possibles
mais si l'on en attend d'autres choses
attend de ce changement et je le pense
localisé en train de
deux conclusions c'est une nouvelle
élection pour un nouveau besançon une
élection à tour finalement les cartes
sont rebattues
nos concitoyens ont tous ont le choix
entre une liste très à gauche
jamais c'était aussi à gauche à besançon
une liste très à droite et sociales nda
qui vient conforter le conservatisme et
l'ultralibéralisme et qui ne ressemble
pas du tout à bien son dernier en août
ne ressemble ni l'autre n'a pu tu
n'habites besançon est donc ce que nous
proposons c'est une liste qui est au
coeur de la sociologie bisontine
une liste qui ressemble à besançon qui
traite de façon équivalente économie
écologie solidarité et sekurit merci
beaucoup merci madame merci messieurs
nous allons vous retrouver tous les
trois jeudi prochain même endroit même
heure france 3 franche comté 18 heures
et cette fois-ci vous répondrai aux
questions des téléspectateurs
demain à 18 heures jérémy chevreuil
animera le débat consacré un vendeur
mandeure et ses cinq candidats et oui
c'est une quinqua qu'un congolais
c'est pas facile à dire et en plus c'est
moche voilà merci beaucoup merci de
votre attention
bonne soirée le journal dans quelques
instants au revoir
[Musique]